okay
and here we go again
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your favorite podcast
[Music]
is
[Music]
y'all welcome to ripping with griffin
and we're back again and i'm gonna be uh
talking about my trip to arizona
got some thoughts about the world and uh
you know
maybe some bitchin like i normally do
but once again thank you for being here
live and i love you all
and welcome back to ramsey
[Music]
yeah whoa here we go live in full effect
man
live in full effect riffing with griffin
this is how i do it i
needed to do it uh like this this way
just because i've had just a
very long weekend had a long ass weekend
i had to do
an audition i had to do um
the traveling everything was new so i
just wanted to tell y'all how it was i
went to
arizona phoenix stand up live and i just
want to tell you everything that
happened
all my thoughts about traveling and
since this is my first time going on the
road
in a year you know excuse me
it was a lot so welcome to the show i
know you guys are trickling in and
wanted it you know
slowly at a time but you know this is
how i do my podcast for you people
listening
you know you're going to be listening
later um thank you for listening and
you guys always thank you for watching
uh you know make sure you
check me out on eric griffin gaming
that's on twitch
i i i'm on there most days you know
mostly every day i don't really have a
set schedule and on saturday mornings i
play with the fans i do private matches
with friends and fans so if you're
interested in that come on out and check
that out on saturday mornings at 10 a.m
pacific time so i do that so anyways
and again like i said everybody welcome
to riffing with griffin i got the chat
open so i'll try to look at that
as much as i can and i just i just
wanted to come on and really just tell
you by recap
but before i even do any of that kind of
stuff too i also want to say this this
is live in full effect it's march 1st
i want to say happy birthday to my
beautiful fiance
rachel she turns 32 today so
uh happy birthday to her uh 22
she looks 22 you know 32 today but looks
22 so
kudos for her to her and to me
just kidding not really but so ha so if
you guys have a chance an opportunity uh
if you really want to help her out go
out and give rachel a follow she has her
own channel now
i'll put the link in the description
down there later but you know
just help rachel out because she's
trying to get a little vlog going where
she wants to it's not necessarily a
podcast she just likes to do little
videos about how to
put on her face routine or just
whatever's on her mind because she just
wants to
you know do like because she watches a
lot of those blogs about purses and all
this kind of stuff and she was like i
want to do that too and i was like i
support it i'm encouraging of it but
so happy birthday to her and if you want
to reach out to her on her instagram
please you know just send her a little
thing happy birthday she'd really like
that so
happy birthday out there to rachel so
i'm doing this live and when you do it
live it makes me really take a pause and
try to be more thoughtful about the
things that i say and the things that i
talk about and how i talk about it
because you know
it's live you know what i mean uh you
know a lot of times you can be on a pi
i've
done podcasts um where when i'm done
the the host will say is there anything
you wanted me to take out
and i'm just like usually i'm like not
really i mean i like to say what i feel
in the moment
yeah you know but you know there is
times you know especially as a comedian
you just say some off-color thing and
then
in this day and age you say something
wrong next thing you know you know
everybody's on your case
because they take everything out of
context you know but anyways i actually
want to talk about that kind of stuff
later
so is what it is um
so let's let's just go with i went to
stand up live in phoenix
uh and this is the first time i've you
know
traveled uh been in another city in an
entire year man
it was something else so first i had
this like really early flight uh i fly
united airlines
you know and so i'm packing and then i
realized when i was packing man i was
like damn i don't even know how to
travel anymore
i used to have it down to a science you
know what i mean you get it down to a
science where you're like you have your
your toiletries you have all this stuff
but during the pandemic i actually moved
so everything's all over the place still
and you know i haven't even thought
about like
packing a suitcase or how i pack a
suitcase so i had to get all my
electronics together and then i had to
like pack my xbox i had this little uh
travel kit that i got from games
g-a-e-m-s
shout out to them because it gave me a
free travel kit and it's dope it's like
this
i wish i had a picture of it ready to go
but it's like it's great it's got a
built-in monitor
so the xbox or ps4 sit inside of it
you know then you open it up like a
suitcase and then there's a monitor
right there
and you just plug in and you you know
hook up the internet you plug in and
play
when i'm at in the airport i have a long
layover before i would
open up my xbox just i'd be playing in
the airport you could hook it up to
wi-fi you can hook up
you know and a lot of times with these
phones you can use because if you're
doing it for a short time like you know
30 40 minutes you can use your phone's
uh wi-fi connection so
anyway so i had to pack my xbox i got to
pack my ipad my laptop because i'm going
to try to stream
onto your twitch while i'm in the hotel
so i had to have all that stuff
and then i got to pick my outfits that
i'm not that i'm going to wear i'm
terrible at that
and now rachel's there trying to tell me
how to pack you know
she looks in my bag and she's like how
many underwears are you taking and i'm
like i got four
thursday friday saturday sunday that's
all i need she was like only four
you have to what you have to you need
your day underwear then you need your
night underwear
and that's a dude i'm like no you got
your thursday underwear
and let me let you know thursday
underwear
it trickles over into friday because if
you're sleeping and you wake up in it
you're walking around a little bit
before you take a shower or not
so so she like put more underwear in my
bag so now i had like extra underwear to
go
to the on the thing so it was an early
flight we had to get to the airport by
like
7 00 am no sick actually it was like we
had to get to like 6 30 or something
like that so
i haven't been to lax in a while and
it's like different they they're
building stuff
and then i'm also again i'm scared about
this is my first time venturing out
um without having as much fear about
kovid that you first had say a year ago
i didn't know what it was i don't know
how you can catch it and then i'm
reading these articles like
united airlines is putting out a bunch
of information you know they had this
article about like they've done studies
and tests and it's proven that
you you almost have zero chance of
catching covet
on an airplane because of the filtration
systems and they got the money to
do that this fancy air thing so the air
is just coming in and out it's not like
you know covets sitting in this in the
plane i mean you know
they say that but you think like if
there's somebody sitting next to me who
actually is sick and they're like coffin
but i guess that kind of person wouldn't
be able to get on the plane
or you would hope that person wouldn't
get on the plane but anyways
you know so i felt a little nervous
about that
um but you know i get on the plane then
you have to wear a mask and i just i
hate wearing masks it's uncomfortable i
got glasses i didn't bring a face shield
i was like contemplating back and forth
do i bring a face shield should i bring
my face shield you know
then you think oh i got to worry about
that so you know so i get to the airport
i
i get through the security it's actually
very simple there wasn't even a lot of
people there
it was just like it was before and i'm
like i got a global entry i got you know
tsa pre
i got clear so you know i'm right in the
line i get to the thing
and then the lounge is open too so i had
enough time so i went into the lounge
now the lounge was completely different
usually they used to have like
buffet style like there's some fruit
there's some oatmeal there's you get
your own coffee you get all the stuff
all that stuff gone it's all gone to me
that's a dog and pony show to me that's
just for optics
in california you know i don't know
what's going on in california but
because like there was a couple that was
looking there and i said to them well i
guess the lounge isn't worth it anymore
if it's gonna be like this because to
get coffee
you had to go to this woman who's
sitting you know she's standing there
um by herself uh you know and you had to
go
and be like yeah can i get some coffee
you know what i mean can i get uh
you know can i get and then she has to
get it for you when it's all sectioned
off and she gets you the coffee then i
was like
can't get a break then she said well we
have breakfast burritos but i'd go get
it for you and it was like this weird
plastic
it was terrible and i thought and i said
to this couple i go well this looks like
a dog and pony show now me because they
say yeah because
we just came from another place and it's
regular it's just regular you go in you
get what you want that kind of stuff
so i just go well you know like which
what's right
you know what i mean because as these
numbers are going down and a lot of it
has to do with you know the vaccine is
out there like
and actually because they've given the
vaccine to the people that are
most at risk funny how all the numbers
are going down
everything's going down you know even
though some places are
handling it one way in terms of like
being open or closed
and then other places like so does it
even have to do with any of that stuff
it's just very strange to me it's
frustrating it's annoying i'm not a
scientist i don't have all the facts i
don't know
most of you aren't scientists don't have
all the facts people just have what they
hear
and they have their own opinion you know
but my opinion is like i don't know why
california has been shut down the way
it's shut down i don't think it's done
any more or less than it would have done
just like every other place
but anyway so i get to my gate i get on
the plane
i actually got upgraded but it was a
little playing cause it's just an hour
flight to phoenix so i was sitting in a
like like it was like one seat a and
then it's like b and c is they're
together but my seat was by itself so
i'm sitting by myself i got my mask on
it was fine i got used to it get to
phoenix
the guy's there to pick me up he hits me
up and you know i go we get in the car
we get to the hotel
once i checked into the hotel and i was
in the hotel i was like oh okay
this is normal everything's fine you
know i was like okay here we are
um so i
then this is where it got weird for me
because this is now i'm in a city i
haven't i haven't been out of la in a
year i i can
count on my hands probably how many
times i've gone out
i mean you know it's a handful of times
that i've even gone out in a year
you know i've only done like five or six
shows uh
you know even when we i order everything
uh you know so maybe i've gone out in a
year
maybe 25 times actually if i if i really
think about it so it's more than my two
hands you know
but still that's not a lot of times in
365 days
to go out you know so now i'm out you
know
i got my mask on and then that's like i
want to get something to eat so i'm in
arizona
the restaurants are open you know what
i'm saying so i go down
to this restaurant outside the hotel
very nice hotel too
um right next to the club you know like
in the club's in this sort of downtown
area they got like bars and restaurants
and everything's like you know
everything's open you know people are
sitting outside people sitting inside
but they're safe everybody's got their
mask on
the things are pulled apart i mean to me
it's just this is common sense
yes we could still open a restaurant
we're just not going to have people
sitting on top of each other
you know like what the [ __ ] are we doing
in california
like it makes no sense to me while we're
just ruining people's lives
for optics and that's what it is guys
it's for
optics it's so the twitter mob
and all the people that think they know
everything doesn't get upset
so this is the way we do it so we have
to make everybody suffer to make these
idiots happy
right so because it to me it's like okay
let's be safe
let's make sure high-risk people are
quarantined or
that they that they have their own time
to go to the store like we're trying to
do or like you know
let's make sure people that are at high
risk we have to let's make them
make sure they're okay but for everyone
else it's like yeah we can open a
restaurant
just spread things apart yes we can go
to stores yes we can go to
outdoor comedy shows you know what i
mean yes you can go
do things you know yes you can go to
dodger stadium and watch a game because
you got people spread out or like
all the things that we got we've come
used to let's just you know let's do
those things but of course we didn't do
that stuff
you know so now here we are right anyway
so
i walk down i go into the restaurant and
man i i'll tell you i felt like i was
institutionalized you know i felt like
california has me i got stockholm
syndrome in california too trying to
defend california like well you know get
it
but really i felt like uh i felt like
morgan freeman in the shawshank
redemption
you know when he he finally got released
from prison and he's working at the
supermarket
and he don't even know how to act can i
go to the bathroom boss because that's
how i felt in this restaurant had my
mask on and everybody else got their
mask off
in their seats i'm saying the staff got
their mask on and i'm like i don't even
know
can i sit over there and you know and i
said you know like man i went into the
bathroom and i
carved on the on on the bathroom ceiling
get busy living
that's just for you shawshank people so
i ate and then i felt like wow this is
this is different this is cool
you know now the whole time i've been
nervous
about doing shows because i haven't done
a long set and i got to do an hour and
my boy michael yo
is on the show he lives in vegas now so
he's really close to this it's easy
flight for him and he just wants to come
and work some stuff out he normally he
headlines his own shows but
because he lives so close he just wants
to pop onto shows and work out his
material i totally get that so he popped
on the show
so we're going to do a two-man show he
does about 20 30 and i was gonna do an
hour
and i'm sitting here like and i remember
the first time i ever did an hour it was
in
butte montana butte montana i was
working for this guy named
tribble his name is david tribble and he
had this montana run where you just go
to montana and you drive all over
montana and do these shows
so when you're featuring it's a two-man
show uh you do like
half hour as a feature then you do an
hour as a headliner that's how they used
to do it you would drive around you
drive hours every day to get to these
different cities on montana
so i remember going i remember the first
time i did an hour
i wasn't ready to do an hour i knew i
wasn't ready to do an hour
so i just i'll never forget it i walked
up on stage and i said to myself well
here we go you know and then i just you
know i did it you stretch
you know you work out all the jokes you
can but it actually you know
if i remember correctly it was like it
wasn't my best set ever but
after i was done i was like oh i could
do this so i have all these feelings
going on
i got my notebook i've been writing for
for four or five days just
in preparation of thinking like oh man
you know i should talk about this
i'm forgetting how my set goes i'm
thinking like oh man i haven't really
thought about this
it's not like riding a bike you know you
do forget the little nuances of your uh
of your jokes the little inflections
that make your joke okay so
um so i you know so then michael's on
stage he's doing his thing i'm pacing in
the green room thinking about what i
need to think about and i go out
and it's a nice crowd on thursday but
it's not sold out you know
and then i just went out on stage and
i had my notebook there too i told him i
prefaced it like hey guys this is my
first time being out of town in a year
and blah blah blah
and then by the end of that set man it
was as if i
never left you know i just felt so good
it was cathartic it was like i was like
yeah
baby i still got it i was strutting
around the stage doing crowd work
you know doing jokes new jokes that i
just came up with that i wrote i'm
working them out and i was like all
right
um i was like yeah baby got it done
you know and then i i felt just great
after that you know
now you know i'm walking into the
restaurant i know what i do you get over
to the restaurant take your mask off you
order your food
it's just it was just normal for me at
that point you know
and then i do the friday shows and
they're packed they're practically sold
out you know
and i do the shows and then you know
it's great i'm working this stuff out
i'm trying to work out this material
now the thing about what i'm gonna get
into now is like something did happen
while i was there
you know people forget that
i'm just working out material
look we all including myself we're not
as
brilliant as we think we are you know
we're also not we we don't always
communicate or articulate our points
as well as we think they are in our head
because in your head you have all the
details
in your head you know what you're trying
to say and in your head it makes sense
we don't always have the words
constructed
in a sentence properly to make people
hear us and understand
so a lot of times with a comic with a
comedian
you know we're on the road because we're
trying to work out the best possible way
to say this to get our point across
and you know like i say sometimes we
fail
so i am working out a bunch of material
and the way i do comedy is i really like
to attack both sides i like to see
both sides of an argument example would
be
i'm not just going to be up there
talking about republicans or like i'm
not going to be up there being like
trump sucks trump sucks
uh i might i might be up there and be
like yeah trump sucks but hillary
clinton sucks too and this is why
you know i'm gonna do that you know i
like to pick out both sides because i do
like when
especially when a conservative
republican type person comes up to me
after the show and they say that to me
they go
i appreciate that you talked about both
sides
because a lot of things are one-sided
but you know that being said though even
still you're gonna say
things and people are gonna be upset
there's always gonna be a butt of the
joke
okay and the butt of the joke sometimes
doesn't like getting slapped
or sometimes when it gets slapped
they're going to be like oh i like that
oh i get it oh that was good
sometimes they're going to be like hey i
didn't like that at all it's just the
nature of comedy
um you know that that it is what it is
so
that being said i have jokes about i
have jokes
the premise of the joke is basically
like i just want to normalize things and
i don't
and i don't care about i don't care the
way
the media makes it feel like we're
supposed to care about certain issues
like for instance being gay
like i don't care like if you're gay i
don't
care no one should care is the point i'm
trying to make in these
in this material you know it's like when
somebody says hey did you hear that
so-and-so is gay
the answer should be so like we need to
get to a point in society where we could
be like
who cares why are you bringing this up
like what does it matter
you know i'm like like i'm a sensitive
guy i'm in touch with my feminine side
very much so i you know you know what i
mean i ain't gonna get into my past it's
under your business like
it doesn't mean like like people's race
gender
and sexual orientation people need to
know this information
so bad so they can put you in a box and
tell you what you can and cannot say
or what you should and should not do
based off their expectations and i say
screw that [ __ ] you know i don't care
like
sometimes this guy hit me up on
instagram one time put this post to say
when you gonna come out of the closet
and then i wrote him back and i said
let's say i do why is that a problem for
you the guy erased it
he erased it because it put it back on
him
because he's making it a big deal you
know when you make it a big deal so if
you're one of these people that like
hates
gays you hate homosexuality why
why that's on you that's your business
keep it to yourself nobody cares
most of us don't care like honestly
even if you you don't have to agree with
everything
but like to the to the point where
you're like actively trying to like
ruin people's life no i think most of us
are just like oh man this again
you know what i mean when something
comes up you ever find yourself thinking
like that like oh
okay people are worrying about that like
who cares anyways
the point in my um
the point in my uh thing is is just
the jokes is just to be like try to like
but at the same time i have to make
jokes within there i'm gonna make jokes
about being gay
i'm gonna make jokes about uh you know
what
you know because to to prove the point
but also it still have to be
entertaining this has to be i'm not
trying to do like like this right now
we're having a discussion
you know i guess some people watch
podcasts because they want to laugh i
need you to like
make me laugh tell funny stories but
when i'm doing solo podcasts like this
this is who i am
when i go on other people's podcasts i
do find myself being more jokey or
whatever but that's you know
i'm i'm going to try to work on it i'm
going to try to balance it out by trying
to be like let me be funny here too so
lighten it up a little bit so you know
so you know so i'm doing these jokes
but i go into a bunch of things i'm
talking about gay but then i go into
talking about being transgender and how
i
feel about the thing you know what i
mean so
i'm not gonna go into all my jokes uh it
goes up and down it's all over the place
but i'm really trying to work it out
but anyways when i get back from the
friday shows which i think went great i
got a great response people are laughing
and hitting me up like oh that was funny
but i got one tweet about somebody was
like i it was like
one of those kind of tweets you know i
was so hurt and insulted
by eric griffin's jokes so you know
insensitive and all this kind of stuff
now my initial reaction to it i was
really
upset you know what i mean i'm really
upset
because in my mind i'm being supportive
even if i'm making some funny jokes
that being transgender is the butt of
the joke
okay i in my mind i am being
supportive because the overall point is
i have nothing wrong with this and no
one should
but so when somebody attacks me like
that
especially publicly that
really made me upset of course i lashed
out i lashed back
shouldn't have done that because then it
was like oh this guy's an [ __ ] and
all this stuff and then
and then some this real this guy's an
idiot okay because and
then i stopped responding i responded to
her and i responded to or him i don't
even know if it was i think it was
someone transgender but i'm not even
sure
you know how that goes to like that's
another confusing thing which is what i
talk about in my act too
it's confusing for us it's hard to like
figure out anyway
so then uh some other guy hits he you
know he he goes in and then he's like oh
what a jerk right and then i respond to
that guy i'm like you weren't even there
you know and then he responds with like
he was like well you know he said
something like
the more you type the more like a jerk
you're being that's not what he said but
that's what he meant you know what and
that hit me
and so i responded again to that guy and
i went you know what you're right
i was just upset because i feel like i'm
being
unfairly it's an unfair characterization
okay so and then i just stopped
responding to it all and i muted it all
so i don't even know what it is i don't
even
i don't i don't even see it anymore you
know because i just muted it all
because then another guy jumps in and
he's like
now this guy was the idiot because he
comes in and he's like you know what
you're a hypocrite
um and then he starts talking about
montez like workaholics like oh you're
doing this stereotype
i actually have decided that you're
racist that's what the guy
said and that's when i checked out
because i was like oh okay
so now we're we're and this is what you
know the
the internet run amok is when that
happens you know
and then it made me just think about
this whole subject man
so let's talk about this now because
this is really what i wanted to talk
about on the podcast today
sensitivity i used to have the idea
when you talk about sensitivity you talk
about cancer culture and we talk about
oh this generation is too sensitive and
i used to feel like
i used to feel like that but i have a
more enlightened opinion on it right now
because i realize
we're all sensitive you know i'm
sensitive
i'm sensitive guy man i watch you know
many times i've watched a twilight saga
this is how sensitive i am i love
twilight
i'm just be honest right now i love the
twilight movies
they're corny and cheesy but they're
soup they're very romantic it's a very
romantic series i actually have read
twilight i read it a bunch of times
i i think it's like a really it's a
really nice romantic
story of the clash of like whatever but
i love the movies and i love at the end
of the second movie
because they play that song a thousand
years and that is such a beautiful song
i swear to god i get teary-eyed every
time i watch the end of
twilight breaking dawn part two when
they're doing the recap and then like
edward and bella are sitting in this
like uh wheat field you know with like
flowers
and then you know she like she you know
how she can't
her mind can't be read by him so she's
practiced a way to like drop that so he
can read her mind and then they're like
i love you forever and it's like
every time i watch it
a little tear comes down on my face
i love it i love that it makes me feel
that way so anyway
this is what i'm saying i am sensitive
so i will change my view
we're all sensitive and it's okay that
you're sensitive i'm not
mad that you're sensitive about jokes
i'm not mad that you feel
what i don't appreciate is how your
sensitivity is weaponized
because a lot of times you have an
opinion
like this woman man this person let's
say oh that's
so you know again i'm probably messing
that up too so you get in trouble for
that
but this person was upset
about my jokes because you know what's
missing from the internet the tweets
everybody should have an opinion and it
should say to me
at the end when we had the metoo
movement we need to start the two
me movement to me
so i think eric griffin is a racist
to me this [ __ ] ain't facts
it's your opinion so in the same thing
with this
this person was hurt and upset about
what i was saying
to them they took it this way it's fair
it's totally fair to feel that way
but when you then take that and put it
on the internet
and have all your people who weren't
even there go oh well it must be true
and that must be it's not like my set
was publicized if it was a special and
it was for public consumption
then yes everyone can then look at it
and be like oh i feel this way that i
feel that then it's like that's but this
is like can we have this moment
like hey walk up to me after the show
hit me up on your own
but no the way people do it now is they
make everything facts based off
their own opinion to me
so then that's what it is so
cancer culture is basically basically
weaponized
sensitivity based off someone's own
interpretation and perception that that
is
taken and it's weaponized against people
i mean come on man you have to now
qualify every statement and then people
like to use
statements and words without details
life is
nuanced man nuance is very important
you know that's my favorite word on the
podcast because it's true life isn't
black and white guys
it's not life is lived in the gray area
and things are also
case by case we live in the nuance
of life
and also we shouldn't always assume
ill intent by everything people say
i don't think the first thing you should
think of is
this is evil you know
you know what i mean like look at this
i'm looking at the chat right now
and here's somebody trying to make a
joke this person says eric reminds me of
michael eric dyson
except he's not smart so is this a joke
like is this person being funny i don't
know this person's intent
okay so as a comic i might be like okay
very funny but i could easily say
this person is a rude [ __ ] who should
get the [ __ ] off my channel
because they obviously don't get me i
could take it like that
i could take it as ill-intent and then i
can take that statement i could put it
online
look how rude and disrespectful this
idiot is in my chat
and then i could take that and put it
online okay
and then now my fans can be like oh man
that person's stupid
that person doesn't know what that you
know and now they attack that person and
that person gets canceled
because what because of how i feel or
i can look at that and be like oh okay
maybe they're just trying to be funny
but they're just not funny like rickvoe
jones
you're not funny because you wrote that
in a way that it's not funny it's
actually mean
so if you're trying to be mean you
succeeded if you're trying to be funny
you did not succeed okay you're
you're not a good joke writer read that
sentence
do you think that's funny now to you you
think it's funny
to you in your mind you're like huh see
i don't know the context
i'm really glad that you did this right
now because i don't know the context of
your terrible sentence
you just wrote that thinking it was
funny to you
to me you thought that was funny right
but
i can look at that now i can sit here
and be like okay i get it
do i have fix i have to have thick skin
and be like oh there's somebody trying
to be funny
okay but he just didn't work but okay i
get it this guy's not a terrible person
all right so that's what happened you
see what i'm saying so this is this is
the kind of thing that happens
so somebody says something like i have
these jokes
people that didn't even hear it people
that weren't even there
they're now attacking me as if i'm a
terrible person
instead of instead of somebody that was
like working out some material
and maybe it didn't hit the way i
thought it was going to hit you know
there's
no there's nothing there it's just it's
just all like
i'm a victim i'm a victim oh no another
comic is
victimizing me right and i'm like nah
man
i'm just trying to be funny and maybe it
didn't work
right like do we have to assume ill
intent at all times but you know we
don't know people's
whatever like i say people aren't always
as deep and smart as they think
they are um
it's like that chick that everybody
canceled from star wars gina whatever
her name is
what's the lady's name chat gina
whatever she was on the mandalorian
now here's the thing with her she made a
terrible analogy in 200 characters
and then she tried to in her mind i'm
not gonna assume ill intent first
in her mind she was trying to make a
point that she didn't have enough
characters to articulate
or obviously the intelligence to make it
work
is she a terrible person i don't know
her well enough to say
but i can't give her the benefit of the
doubt and be like you know what
i don't know if this is warranted all
the attention that it's
gotten now the dude harry kaviso that
plays superman
he's getting flack because he dated her
right because now the internet has
decided
that she's racist the internet has
decided that she hates jews and she's a
terrible person
when i read what she wrote i look and go
well you missed the boat on this one
you made a terrible analogy chalk that
up to like oops that one didn't work
well and you move on
right that's how i look at it because
i'm a comic i've made jokes where i go
well you didn't get that one you hit and
miss
you move on right now we can't do that
you're going to because you're going to
get canceled you can't just move on you
got to make sure that you're saying what
you mean to say
and you know it sucks now again you have
to qualify everything
i am in no way supporting this woman and
whatever you guys think
terrible about her that is not what i'm
doing i'm merely pointing out
there is another side there could
possibly be another side
she could be a hate monger and hate you
know it could be true
but we don't know from that tweet it
could be that she was trying to make a
point and she used a terrible example
and because of that terrible example uh
you know she hurts some people's
feelings
and because she hurts in people's
feelings she should be canceled now that
being said let me bring it back to me
what does that mean for me so this lady
then person that came to the show
i apologize to this person publicly
right here
i wanted to send a message but it's like
i don't you know you're damned if you do
your damage if you don't
but i'm apologizing because her feelings
were hurt
i don't think i did anything like
egregiously wrong
but i can look because i've actually
looked at the material and listed and i
thought you know what
and another friend of mine came to the
show and they had it they said well you
did say this and i was like i didn't say
that
and i was mad because i was like well
that's what it and then they always say
this
well that's what it sounded like that's
what people do
cancer culture does this they take what
they you say
they translate it into what they think
it means to them
to them and then they go well you this
is what you meant
and i'm like that isn't what i meant so
now as a performer
as an artist as someone who writes
things on the internet as someone that
has a podcast
i can now take the time here to qualify
everything that i say
so you know you i don't want to hear
your translation
i'm telling you how the [ __ ] i feel i'm
telling you
you know so it's like
i do not hate transgender people i find
the
the thing to be it could be it's a weird
thing that i don't understand
and because of that there's humor in it
that can be found on both sides and as a
comedian i'm gonna go attack that i'm
not gonna stop talking about it
but i am gonna be more thoughtful about
my words and that's what i
looked at i looked at the material i
wrote it down and i thought okay
i now can see why somebody could take it
this way so let me make sure
i'm doing these jokes in a way that you
understand where i'm coming from
at the end you could be like i don't
find this funny or at the end you could
be like well
i get what you're saying but i don't
agree but ultimately i just want you to
laugh
even if you laugh and go oh that's crazy
you're wrong
but you're laughing so i have to achieve
that
i take that responsibility for myself
and i'm gonna try to do that
so anyways this is you know where we're
at
man so that's to me again let me go over
it again
that's what i think cancer culture is
cancer culture
is weaponized sensitivity based off
people's
own perception of things that may or may
not be right or wrong
but they take it they make it that and
they make it true
and then they attack attack attack and
it shouldn't
it shouldn't work like that you know
there are certain words and phrases that
we have in society
that need details but they're catch-all
statements
that need details it needs nuanced
let me give y'all an example
the word woke when people say
woke i'm woke what does that really mean
what does woke mean so if i look on
google let's look on google right now
and see if google can tell us what the
definition of woke is
so according to google it says alert to
injustice in society
especially racism we need to stay angry
and stay woke
that is i don't believe that definition
at all
because it's not what that that's what
they want you to think it's about
but people use woke
you know here's a better one woke is a
term that organized the united states
referring to a
perceived i love that word
a perceived awareness of issues that
concern social justice and racial
and uh racial justice that's not how
people use woke man
people using it as a catch-all for
everything
it's like when somebody says listen
someone on either side of a subject
can say they're woke i'ma show you right
now
you go to somebody who's pro pro choice
you go to somebody pro choice hey why
are you pro-choice
and they say i'm pro-choice because i'm
woke
go to somebody pro-life ask them why are
you pro-life
you know what they can say it's because
i'm woke
it sounds like both sides are sleep
because you haven't explained anything
you've just used a statement that lets
people
fill in the gaps with their own fantasy
of what they think is right and wrong
you're making yourself feel like you're
right because you say
i'm woke i've had that in a show i've
done jokes and i say to somebody what's
wrong with you why aren't you laughing
and the lady said
i'm not laughing because i'm woke it's
like shut up
you ain't woke right now so woke has
been hijacked
this is what they wanted to mean they
want it to be about injustice in society
they want it to be about
racial injustice and all that now but
people have turned it into
woke means my side is right
and your side is wrong so because we're
right we're woke
nah it doesn't work like that
here's another one so i'm saying is so
you could tell me you're woke but the
next thing you tell me to tell me is
tell me why you're woke
because then i can decide if i agree
with you or not
and with something like abortion you
have
people will have their this is why i'm
pro-choice boom
they feel justified you have the other
side who's like we care about life and
blah blah blah and all those people that
feel the way they feel
so boom boom boom boom they have their
opinion and they could be like that
they could prove why they're woke they
could prove why they're woke and then
you can decide yourself with those
details and information you can go
okay i agree with this side or
that side you know it's up to you
here's another here's another statement
that is a catch-all people use all the
time
that to me needs to be unpacked
victim blaming you know when people say
that
you know you say something they go
you're victim blaming
it's like really am i victim blaming now
what is victim blaming what is you know
it's blaming something happens to
someone and you blame you you you say
it's
the fault of the victim so people use
this as a catch-all with no details no
nuance
it's it annoys the [ __ ] out of me now
back in my day victim blaming and this
is the best example of it
true victim blaming would be a woman
gets
raped and then afterwards
even in court people go well what were
you wearing
how were you acting as if to say
if you dress a certain way you're
allowed
to get raped right so that's where to me
it an oran
there was the origin of victim blaming
because that is
right dead on victim blaming you go
you did this and that's why it happened
to you so it's your fault
but victim blaming has been hijacked
so take that even the same example
some you know somebody goes to now a a
college girl goes to some frat party
there's drinking and whatever is
happening and all this stuff is
happening
she's not she's not even there with
someone she knows you know and some
terrible thing happens
you hear all the details and then you
say
oh man you know probably shouldn't go to
frat parties by yourself probably you
know moving forward
this is a terrible thing that happened
so moving forward hey let's learn from
this you know you shouldn't do maybe
maybe don't go to frat parties by
yourself maybe don't drink with
strangers
okay now it gets tricky because now
someone could say
are you victim blaming so it's her fault
and i'm no
[ __ ] i didn't say that that's not what
i [ __ ] said we're talking about
preventative for future things so you
got to qualify everything
i am in no way saying that this is
person's fault i'm just saying in the
future for other people
maybe we should uh you know think take
another
look because there are terrible people
out there so so in the event to try to
avoid those terrible people
let's make sure you're with somebody
that you you feel safe with let's say
make sure that you're not drinking with
strangers like you know
that's you have to qualify it like that
here's a an example of when we don't
have to do that
um you you go out on the town
you drive someplace you get hit by a
drunk driver
you get you break your arm and then i
say to you
did you have your seatbelt on and they
say i wasn't wearing my seatbelt
damn now is it your fault that a drunk
driver hit you
not at all is it your fault you broke
your arm no
somebody else made a really terrible
choice and you suffered for it
but when we say wear your seat belt
it's so in the event
you get into an accident this seat belt
might save your life whether it's your
fault or not
that's why you tell people to wear their
seat belt
that's the same that's the analogy of
you're telling a someone you're telling
a young woman or a man
like it's like when it's like when
somebody
one of these actresses or actor because
it happens to both are like
yeah i went to this producer's hotel at
like 9 00 p.m
uh for to discuss an audition to discuss
a part
and he was inappropriate you hear that
and you go
damn that sucks and then
you say after well maybe moving forward
you know don't go to a hotel or somebody
you don't really know make sure it's a
professional setting
and then the twitter mob or people jump
on you the cancer culture jumps on you
oh you're blaming the victim now we're
not blaming the victim
okay let's qualify it we're basically
saying
in the event you might be in an accident
in the event you might run into uh
somebody inappropriate
let's set up your circumstances so you
don't ever have to deal with that
it is not your fault that there's creeps
out there
you know in the same way you might be a
producer who's
leaving town the next day you really
want to see this actress so you hit her
up
yo how man this part is perfect for you
can you can you come by my hotel so we
can discuss this
i really think you're perfect for the
part they have a great talk
nothing bad happens the chick gets the
part and we move on
other people hear about that and then
they say about that producer
uh why would you bring someone to your
hotel you you're that's so
inappropriate nah it's not so is he
you know is he now the victim of because
he had to leave and he had no place to
have this meeting
no it's case by case you see what i'm
saying this is details it's the nuance
the nuance of the details you have to
listen to the whole story then you go oh
okay you know what this worked out
another one might not have worked out
but i am not blaming the victim when i
say to
young actor and actresses yo maybe it's
moving forward let's wear our
you know let's we're let's wear our life
seat belt
and make sure we put ourselves in a safe
situation let's make sure it's a
professional environment
you're not saying it's their fault you
see how you we have to talk like this
now
so people can't parse your words and
make them into whatever the hell they
want
um you know what i mean so
that's what happens it's like there was
this great documentary on
netflix i forgot the name of it but it
was about like
stories of like three or four young
women who were
raped by someone that they knew it was
you know it's like they were 14 and the
boys were like 15
it might have even been like 18 but
whatever it was it was these terrible
stories how the boys
they they didn't go to jail it ruined
these girls lives they had to leave
their towns it was like they were blamed
it was
all this stuff you know and it's like a
very you know interesting life study
about
what's happening uh what happens to
people in these situations where
victims of rape can't come out because
they feel like they're going to be you
know
all that stuff you know what i mean and
it's important to talk about but you
know what they glossed over
in every single case
underage drinking was involved every
single one of them these people were
drinking
and they shouldn't have been okay so if
i now i can look at that and say
hey this is terrible
by the way a woman should be allowed to
be at a party
and be blacked out drunk with her skirt
over her head
and no panties on and she should be able
to be safe
you know you know what i mean this is
not an invitation for you to well she's
asking for it that doesn't exist
you're just a creep if you do that but
you know in a perfect society
you know a guy comes over with a blanket
covers her up
sheila's drunk and then that's the end
of it okay
so we don't live in a society like like
that we live with
this creeps and people around so we have
to make sure we say to sheila later
hey you know what maybe don't drink
around people that
you're not you don't know them that's
just being safe we're not blaming her
we're not blaming her we're just saying
let's in the future
change our behavior so we can be safe
it's the same thing i thought with this
documentary
don't just gloss over underage drinking
that how it warps the mind
how it you know makes you make bad
choices and bad decisions and these kind
of things can happen
it's just a it's just a message to be
like that should be the message you
should be telling all young people hey
not that hey if you underage drink you
might get raped no it's like if you
underage drink
you might not be in the right state of
mind to deal with certain situations
i hate that they just gloss over this
kind of stuff
so here we are i say all that just to
say
i think that we need more conversations
you know and
we can't just take 200 characters that
somebody's saying
on the internet and assuming that we now
know
everything about this person we know
their intent we know what they were
trying to say
you know we we i think we have to be
more we have to be more lenient
i think we have to just back away from
the internet it's like this is not
facts it's not law you know and then i i
extrapolate that more when i'm talking
to like comedy if i'm just out on the
road
you come to the comedy store when it's
open and you see me i'm working some
stuff out i'm working it out
okay yes you're entitled to have your
opinion you're entitled to be like
you need to work that more or oh
that when you were working that out it
really insulted me
i that's fair but what's not fair is to
now
take that go to the internet and be like
that person's terrible he is the worst
person in the world and he's also
racist sexist or whatever it is that you
think you've now made it
law you've made it fact it's now canon
you know that
i am that person because you think that
so i hope that we can
find a way to
get past all this i think find a way to
like really have an
understanding of what this is that just
because somebody tweeted something
it's not law it's not fact
it's not fact it also doesn't mean it's
fiction
but we need some details we need some
details and we need to understand that
there is
nuance to life
who right y'all
now it's uh let's finish off with
a little bitching with griffin
this is my bitching with griffin segment
and then we'll end
the podcast and move on with our lives
um did y'all hear that
hasbro is
making mr potato head
just potato head
you know what i'm gonna get something
okay i'm back
all right so they are taking
mr potato head and they want to make him
now
just potato head
there's only two things
that make mr potato head a man
male the mustache
and the word mr
mr potato head doesn't have a dick
he's already gender neutral
this enough mr potato head is gender
neutral enough
all you gonna do he don't have a dick
he's never had a dick
gender neutral what like what are we
doing
you know it's like this gender neutral
thing it's always when you taking [ __ ]
away from men you know that's what they
do they go well we're gonna make it
gender-neutral
so what we're gonna do is the the
characteristics that make this manly or
male
take them away so it can be more
gender-neutral
well you know what we're gonna take the
titties off barbie
i want the titties removed from barbie
and let's make her gender neutral i need
the hair
cut off all right chop the hair down and
make it short
and take the titties off and we're going
to just have we're just going to call
them
bar so it could be male or female
bar you know what i mean
like mrs potato head by the way what the
the lips and the in the lashes
so now we just have a potato you know
what i mean like
what if i like having my mr and mrs
potato i just
i don't get it but you know what they do
when they take things away from women
they call it gender fluid it's more
gender fluid when you when women say
well i don't want to have all this you
know
i'm i'm i'm fluid so i could be one or
the other
but for for men it's gender new we knew
we got to neutralize
the man [ __ ] neutralize demand [ __ ]
i think it's ridiculous come on come on
man who's
who's bothered by this look i
have no problem with people that say
want to be neutral
want to be uh fluid all right so then we
have now we just have more than one
thing now so we have men
women and we have people in that
category and if there's subcategories of
that that's fine with me
but there are some of us who want mr
potato head i want mr potato head
and i want mrs potato head so they can
be together and i'm like oh mr mr potato
head this is like you know
i i don't want potato head
i don't want just potato head i want
both both potatoes
i want two potatoes i want mr and mrs
potato and then you bring another one in
gender fluid potato and then they have a
little family gender fluid potato head
is like she you know
she's like an exchange student or he's
addiction whoever they are an exchange
student and they living with mr and mrs
potato head
that's it
that's all i have to say about that man
we have mr and mrs potato head and now
they're just making it potato head
and you know like i say i got i got a
problem with it i don't agree with it
and that's within my right to not agree
with it
and you know of course you want to
cancel me for that please
go right ahead but
ladies and gentlemen i want to thank you
again for uh coming to
riffing with griffin live sometimes it's
live sometimes it's not but
i'm here every monday um
i have a guest coming next week so make
sure you look out for that
i might have a great jamie kennedy on
next week he's got a movie coming out so
he's going to be promoting that
i'll be on every day doing eric griffin
gaming so make sure you guys check
that out i just totally appreciate you
guys coming on and watching and
sharing and being a part of you know me
just having a conversation just having a
discussion about life
you know whether i'm right or wrong we
just having to talk having a discussion
and i appreciate
uh you guys being here you know what i
mean i do appreciate you guys being here
and it is what it is so
thank you again for watching riffing
with griffin
[Music]
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]
i'm never spliffing sometimes i be
tiffin with people don't like what i say
but i do the [ __ ] in my own way
that's why i play if you religious
just pray
[Music]
that's that dad [ __ ] right there all
right guys thanks for watching roofing
with griffin and mix and one more time
happy birthday to the lovely rachel and
you guys are great
please share subscribe and do all that
great stuff
and i will see you
next week thanks again
[Music]
you